其他人：感觉不够
Others: Feels like it's not enough.
Tasha: 不会吧够了吧
Tasha: No way, it should be enough.
Tasha: 还多再把巧克力
Tasha: There's more, add some chocolate.
Tasha: 没办法没过去的
Tasha: Can't help it, it didn't go through.
Tasha: 鸡蛋确实都是这个味啊确实
Tasha: Eggs do taste like this, indeed.
Tasha: 我我在想找个筷子呢
Tasha: I, I was thinking of finding some chopsticks.
Tasha: 没事没事
Tasha: It's okay, it's okay.
Tasha: 这个干了的
Tasha: This one's dried up.
Tasha: 哎拿水拿水
Tasha: Hey, get some water, get some water.
Tasha: 做提拉米苏吧
Tasha: Let's make tiramisu.
Tasha: 蘸酱麻薯这
Tasha: Dip the mochi in sauce.
Tasha: 个超级简单
Tasha: This is super easy.
Tasha: 这个等这个烤好就送进去
Tasha: Once this is baked, send it in.
Tasha: 平底锅没有吧
Tasha: We don't have a frying pan, right?
Tasha: 只有平底锅哦
Tasha: We only have a frying pan.
Tasha: 你想煎牛排是吧
Tasha: You want to fry the steak, right?
Tasha: 你翻翻柜子
Tasha: Check the cupboards.
Tasha: 我说很会煎牛排吗
Tasha: Am I good at frying steak?
Alice:哎露西亚你在吗
Alice: Hey Lucia, are you here?
Alice:露西亚在吗
Alice: Lucia, are you here?
Alice:不在
Alice: Not here.
Alice:我要知道
Alice: I need to know.
其他人：现在煎吗
Others: Fry it now?
Tasha: 现在煎
Tasha: Fry it now.
其他人：就他只要裂开就跟那差不多
Others: Once it cracks, it's almost done.
Tasha: 没有里面没熟
Tasha: No, it's not cooked inside.
Tasha: 这个倒进去这三个
Tasha: Pour these three in.
Alice:哈哈哈
Alice: Hahaha
Tasha: 这太懂了吧你
Tasha: You know this too well.
Tasha: 能撕的开吗
Tasha: Can you tear it open?
Tasha: 我去帮你拿个剪刀
Tasha: I'll get you some scissors.
Tasha: 我有
Tasha: I have them.
Jake:哈哈
Jake: Haha
Tasha: 刀把啊
Tasha: The knife handle.
Tasha: 捋开是吗
Tasha: Open it up, right?
Tasha: 哎到这
Tasha: Hey, over here.
其他人：奶油吗
Others: Cream?
其他人：这个是
Others: This is...
Tasha: 马斯卡彭
Tasha: Mascarpone.
Alice:提拉米苏的
Alice: For tiramisu.
Tasha: 做提拉米苏专用
Tasha: Specifically for tiramisu.
Tasha: 你可以把这个边边都拿开
Tasha: You can remove the edges.
Tasha: 这样的话就完全挤出来
Tasha: That way it squeezes out completely.
Tasha: 黑笔我上楼拿一下
Tasha: I'll go upstairs to get a black pen.
Tasha: 正儿八经剪刀
Tasha: Real scissors.
其他人：黑笔是干什么
Others: What's the black pen for?
Alice:黑笔写字的
Alice: For writing.
其他人：写提拉米苏吗
Other person: Write Tiramisu?
Alice:那倒不是哈哈
Alice: Not really, haha.
Alice:其他人：
Alice: Other person:
Alice:你可以吃
Alice: You can eat it.
Tasha: 好好吃吗
Tasha: Is it really tasty?
Alice:可以
Alice: Yes.
Tasha: 是啊这些东西都美味
Tasha: Yeah, all these things are delicious.
Tasha: 要加糖的
Tasha: You need to add sugar.
其他人：这是牛奶
Other person: This is milk.
Tasha: 酸度调节剂
Tasha: Acidity regulator.
Alice:是不跟吃油一样嗯
Alice: It's not like eating oil, hmm.
Alice:哈哈哈哈哈哈
Alice: Hahahahaha.
Alice:好好笑
Alice: So funny.
其他人：这就是奶奶加油的黄油也是
Other person: This is like butter with added oil from grandma.
Alice:嗯
Alice: Yeah.
其他人：四个三个都加进去
Other person: Four, three, put them all in.
Tasha: 这这剪刀
Tasha: This, this scissors.
Tasha: 我觉得
Tasha: I think...
其他人：你把那个这样
Other person: You take that like this.
其他人：把这个给
Other person: Give this...
其他人：打开我还是拿刀吧
Other person: Open it, I'd better use a knife.
其他人：你下边两脚没开
Other person: You didn't open the bottom two legs.
Tasha: 我没开完呢
Tasha: I haven't finished opening it.
Tasha: 你让我接这个了
Tasha: You asked me to handle this.
其他人：好问题不大
Other person: It's fine, no big deal.
Tasha: 不能浪费
Tasha: Can't waste it.
其他人：倒特别干净
Other person: Pour it thoroughly.
Tasha: 不用倒特别干净
Tasha: No need to pour it thoroughly.
Tasha: 很贵的这个
Tasha: This is expensive.
其他人：是吗
Other person: Really?
Tasha: 是啊这一包多少钱
Tasha: Yeah, how much is this pack?
其他人：这一包多少钱
Other person: How much is this pack?
Tasha: 一包二三十啊
Tasha: A pack is twenty or thirty.
Alice:一盒得二三十吧
Alice: A box is about twenty or thirty, right?
其他人：提拉米苏这么成本这么高
Other person: Tiramisu costs that much to make?
Tasha: 是的
Tasha: Yes.
Tasha: 尤其是如果你想做很垃圾的提拉米苏
Tasha: Especially if you want to make a really bad Tiramisu.
Tasha: 其实很便宜
Tasha: It's actually cheap.
Tasha: 但是想要做很纯正的就很贵
Tasha: But if you want to make a really authentic one, it's expensive.
Alice:能做一排
Tasha: 12个吧
Tasha: 12, right?
Alice:恩一盘
Alice: Yeah, then one tray.
Tasha: 对就是一板
Tasha: Yeah, just one tray.
Tasha: 就刚刚那么就这么大一盘
Tasha: Just like that, it's one big tray.
其他人：那一个做4个
Others: Then make 4 each.
Tasha: 对所以挑
Tasha: Yeah, so pick.
其他人：这一个就卖68
Others: This one sells for 68.
Tasha: 对啊所以才会卖的贵吧我觉得
Tasha: Yeah, that's why it's expensive, I guess.
Tasha: 而且这用的都是最好的原料了
Tasha: And it's made with the best ingredients.
Alice:嗯
Alice: Right.
Alice:我们买抹茶粉也是很好的
Alice: We bought really good matcha powder too.
其他人：其他女生能做抹茶味
Others: Other girls can make matcha flavor.
Alice:那就是你的那个胚跟底是一样的
Alice: So your base and the bottom are the same.
Alice:就看你上面撒什么粉嗯
Alice: It's just about what powder you sprinkle on top.
其他人：搅
Others: Stir.
Alice:用那个打发
Tasha: 搅拌
Tasha: Stir.
其他人：哦就跟那个面包似的
Others: Oh, like making bread.
其他人：做那个蛋糕似的
Others: Like making a cake.
Alice:你做过蛋糕吗
Alice: Have you made a cake before?
其他人：没做过但我看看
Others: Never, but I've seen it done.
其它人：其实想做
其他人： 等下过生日去做
Others: Do it for a birthday.
其他人：有很多那种什么情侣的那个
Others: There are lots of couples' activities.
其他人： 什么项目
Others: What kind of activities?
Tasha: 我今天买了淡奶油呢
Tasha: I bought some whipped cream today.
Alice:在右边吗
Alice: Is it on the right?
Tasha: 不在
Tasha: No, it's not.
其他人：这我得按一个方向搅
Others: I have to stir in one direction.
Alice:是的
Alice: Yes.
其他人：如果不是会怎么样
Others: What happens if I don't?
Alice:不知道
Alice: No idea.
Tasha: 我今买的淡奶油呢
Tasha: I bought whipped cream today.
Alice:放进去了吗
Alice: Did you put it in?
Tasha: 我今天放进来了呀
Tasha: I put it in today.
Tasha: 难道被拿到楼上去了
Tasha: Did someone take it upstairs?
其他人：这这
Others: This, this...
Tasha: 哎谁拿出来的
Tasha: Hey, who took it out?
其他人：你拿出来的吧
Others: Didn't you take it out?
Tasha: 我吗
Tasha: Me?
Alice:这是今天买的还是上次买的呀
Alice: Did you buy this today or last time?
Tasha: 今天刚到
Tasha: It just arrived today.
Tasha: 哎今天啊这个也是
Tasha: Yeah, today, this too.
其他人：今天买的今天买的
Others: Bought today, bought today.
Tasha: 盆哎
Tasha: The pot, yeah.
其他人：可以了吗
Others: Is it okay now?
Tasha: 可以了呀然后放上来呃好吧
Tasha: Yes, it's fine, then put it up here, um, okay.
其它人：然后就稍微你弄就行
Alice: Then you just need to do it a bit.
Tasha: 没关系
Tasha: It's alright.
Alice:无妨
Alice: No problem.
Tasha: 你这样子
Tasha: You do it like this.
其他人：你加吧
Others: You add it.
Tasha: 没关系叫500颗
Tasha: It's okay, call for 500 pieces.
Tasha: 这个这袋子用完就
Tasha: Once this bag is used up...
其他人：他这上面不是写了大概多少克
Others: Doesn't it say roughly how many grams on it?
Tasha: 这个还真是被点了就
Tasha: This one really has been counted.
其他人：嗯哦哦
Others: Oh, oh.
Alice:小半一点点
Alice: A little bit more.
Tasha: 捋开
Tasha: Spread it out.
其他人：可不好拿刀剪
Others: It's hard to cut with a knife.
其他人：剪刀刚才剪刀呢
Others: Where are the scissors from earlier?
Tasha: 剪刀
Tasha: Scissors.
Alice:那那那
Alice: There, there, there.
其他人：加500 是吧
Others: Add 500, right?
其他人：对多少
Others: Yes, how much?
Tasha: 对加500一共500
Tasha: Yes, add 500, a total of 500.
Tasha: 刚才你加了130了
Tasha: You added 130 earlier.
Tasha: 可以了吧
Tasha: Is it okay now?
Tasha: 用这个用这个
Tasha: Use this, use this.
其他人：就这
Others: Just this.
其他人：现在那个披萨只能加这么多东西
Others: Now the pizza can only add this much stuff.
Tasha: 把它搅拌
Tasha: Stir it.
Alice:还得加蛋液吧
Alice: Do we still need to add egg mixture?
Tasha: 对这这个这个
Tasha: Yes, this one, this one.
Tasha: 蛋液什么的要先去啊
Tasha: The egg mixture and stuff need to go first.
其他人：没事弄熟了我去搞
Others: No problem, once cooked, I'll handle it.
Tasha: 我去搞蛋液那一部分啊
Tasha: I'll handle the egg mixture part.
Tasha: 你把它打发成那种膏状
Tasha: You whip it into a paste.
Alice:需要我帮你什么吗
Alice: Do you need my help?
Tasha: 不用嗯不用
Tasha: No, no need.
Tasha: 很简单
Tasha: It's simple.
Alice:手指饼干呢
Alice: Where are the ladyfingers?
Alice:我给他拿出来吧
Alice: I'll get them out.
其他人：这就跟调麻酱
Others: It's just like mixing sesame paste.
Alice:酒
Alice: Wine.
Alice:哎手指饼干在哪里
Alice: Hey, where are the ladyfingers?
Tasha: 手指饼干在这呢
Tasha: The ladyfingers are here.
Alice:OK
Alice:那个
Tasha: 60克水
Tasha: 60 grams of water.
Alice:你是要沾这个液吧对
Alice: You need to dip them in this liquid, right?
其他人：像那个就是蛋糕上面抹
Others: It's like spreading it on a cake.
Alice:奶油
Alice: Cream.
其他人：奶油抹也可以这么做
Others: You can do it with cream too.
Tasha: 你不是加带奶油进去了吗
Tasha: Didn't you add cream to it?
其他人：他那那他那种奶就是那种奶油
Others: That kind, that kind of cream.
Alice:就是是牛奶打发
Alice: It's whipped milk.
其他人：就牛奶加
Others: Just add milk.
其他人：这个洗奶油
Others: This is whipped cream.
Alice:不用就是牛奶加糖
Alice: No, just milk and sugar.
其他人：加糖
Others: Add sugar.
Alice:嗯
Alice: Yeah.
其他人：那为什么刚才打的那个你说不是
Others: Then why did you say the one we just whipped wasn't?
Tasha: 刚打哪个
Tasha: Which one did we just whip?
其他人：那个就是
Others: That one.
Tasha: 那个没加带奶油呀我们
Tasha: That one didn't have cream in it.
其他人：你刚不是说牛奶加糖
Others: Didn't you just say milk and sugar?
其他人：就是淡奶油啊
Others: That's light cream.
其他人：淡奶油加牛奶加糖
Others: Light cream with milk and sugar.
Alice:什么没听懂
Alice: What? I didn't get it.
其他人：就是那个蛋糕上面那个奶
Others: The cream on top of the cake.
Alice:那个就是奶加糖打
Alice: That's just milk and sugar whipped together.
Alice:但是你用手打打不出来
Alice: But you can't whip it by hand.
Alice:得用那个高速的打
Alice: You need a high-speed mixer.
其他人：哦对啊
Others: Oh, right.
其他人：那咱刚才做的那个
Others: So the one we made earlier.
其他人：第一个不就是加了这些吗
Others: The first one had those ingredients, right?
Tasha: 没加这些呀
Tasha: No, it didn't.
其他人：咱第一个不是加水和油
Others: The first one had water and oil.
其他人： 然后就然后就加了那个蛋清和糖吗
Others: And then we added egg whites and sugar, right?
Tasha: 哦所以才问奶油问
Tasha: Oh, so you were asking about the cream.
其他人： 所以那不就是蛋糕奶油吗
Others: So that was the cake cream.
Alice:不用奶油不用加鸡蛋
Alice: No cream, no eggs.
其他人： 要不说奶和糖就是奶和糖
Others: If you say milk and sugar, it’s milk and sugar.
Alice:奶和糖是奶油
Alice: Milk and sugar make cream.
Alice:不加鸡蛋
Alice: No eggs.
其他人：要加油吗
Others: Do we need oil?
Alice:不加
Alice: No.
其他人：真的吗
Others: Really?
Alice:骗你干嘛
Alice: Why would I lie to you?
其他人：那是旺仔牛奶
Others: That's Wangzai milk.
其他人：直接把旺仔牛奶搅拌
Others: Just blend the Wangzai milk.
其他人：再搅拌搅拌就是奶油
Others: Blend it more, and it's cream.
Alice:旺仔牛奶
Alice: Wangzai milk.
Tasha: 刚刚你那一个鸡蛋
Tasha: The egg you had earlier...
Tasha: 哦搁这呢
Tasha: Oh, here it is.
Alice:不太行吧
Alice: Is that okay?
Alice:旺仔牛奶可以了
Alice: Wangzai milk is fine.
其他人：可以了
Others: It's fine.
其他人：这边抹到抹到什么上面
Others: What do we spread this on?
Alice:这个还得加可生食鸡蛋的蛋液
Alice: We still need to add edible raw egg liquid.
其他人：蛋清
Others: Egg whites?
Alice:不是蛋液的蛋黄吧
Alice: No, the egg yolk from the egg liquid.
其他人：还要加什么
Others: What else to add?
Alice:打黄叶吧
Alice: Beat the yolk.
Tasha: 接那个跑腿
Tasha: Answer the errands.
Tasha: 你接你接
Tasha: You answer, you answer.
Tasha: 不用不用
Tasha: No need, no need.
Tasha: 好了好了你说吧
Tasha: Okay, okay, you talk.
Tasha: 你跟他说话
Tasha: You talk to him.
其他人：喂你好
Others: Hello?
其他人：啊您在哪
Others: Ah, where are you?
Tasha: 您出去找他吧
Tasha: You go out and find him.
Alice:我去吧
Alice: I'll go.
Alice:太热了
Alice: It's too hot.
其他人：在53号楼门口是吧
Others: At the entrance of Building 53, right?
Alice:53 好好好
Alice: 53, okay, okay.
其他人： 好好好
Others: Okay, okay.
其他人：我去找你
Others: I'll find you.
其他人：那我去吧
Others: I'll go then.
Alice:你能拿着吗
Alice: Can you carry it?
Alice:我跟你一块
Alice: I'll come with you.
Tasha: 对有好多
Tasha: Yeah, there are a lot.
Alice:你知道这个门的密码吗
Alice: Do you know the code for this door?
Alice:他在哪呢
Alice: Where is he?
其他人：你看一下
Others: Check it out.
其他人：矿泉水是在这个厨房里的
Others: The mineral water is in this kitchen.
Alice:不知道
Alice: I don't know.
其他人：刚给你打电话
Others: Just called you.
其他人：有一个那个码
Others: There's a code.
其他人：有个码是吗嗯
Others: There's a code, right?
Alice:我的那个
Alice: My...
Alice:好像也能提着
Alice: I think I can carry it too.
Alice:这个沉吗
Alice: Is this heavy?
其他人：沉倒是不沉
Others: It's not heavy.
其他人：就是不怎么好
Others: It's just not very good.
其它人：你能拿吗
Alice:可以可以
Alice: Sure, sure.
Alice:嗯
Alice: Hmm.
Alice:哎呦
Alice:这就叫绝不认输的中国女人
Alice: This is what you call an indomitable Chinese woman.
Alice:哎呀
Alice: Oh dear.
Alice:呜有空位吗
Alice: Is there a free spot?
Alice:哎呦我的天呐
Alice: Oh my goodness.
Alice:这搁哪
Alice: Where should we put this?
Tasha: 放地上吧
Tasha: Put it on the floor.
Alice:放地上我们在二楼还是一楼吃
Alice: Put it on the floor? Are we eating on the second floor or the first floor?
Tasha: 哦那应该在二楼吃是吧
Tasha: Oh, should we eat on the second floor?
Alice:在一楼吧
Alice: Let's eat on the first floor.
Tasha: 在一楼这怎么吃
Tasha: How do we eat on the first floor?
Alice:要不你看阳台
Alice: Why don't you check the balcony?
Alice:哎不是阳台
Alice: Oh, not the balcony.
其他人：这一会底感觉要糊啊
Others: This batch feels like it's going to burn.
Tasha: 完了
Tasha: Oh no.
其他人：糊了
Others: It's burnt.
Alice:熟了
其他人：你先给它倒出来
Alice: It's done, pour it out first.
其他人：然后再换
Others: Then replace it.
其他人：换个盆
Others: Change the bowl.
Tasha: 过筛一下吧等会
Tasha: Sieve it later.
其他人：换壳加热
Others: Reheat with a different shell.
Tasha: 怎么熟这么快我靠
Tasha: How did it cook so fast, oh my god.
Alice:是是熟了吗
Alice: Is it really done?
Tasha: 没有没有没有没关系
Tasha: No, no, no, it's okay.
Alice:你你是哪个学院的
Alice: Which college are you from?
其他人：那个学院
Others: Which college?
Alice:嗯
Alice: Hmm.
Tasha: 学院计算机吧
Tasha: Computer science, I think.
其他人：人人工智能计算机好没
Others: Artificial Intelligence and Computer Science, right?
Alice:不是你们那个全称叫啥
Alice: What's the full name of your college?
其他人：就叫人工智能
Others: Just Artificial Intelligence.
Alice:人工智能学院嗯
Alice: Artificial Intelligence College, hmm.
Alice:哎
Alice: Hey.
Tasha: 哎呀这很着急
Tasha: Oh my, this is so urgent.
Alice:帮你搅一下
Alice: Let me stir it for you.
其他人：我怕你烫到我
Others: I'm afraid you'll burn me.
其他人：开空调哈哈哈
Others: Turn on the air conditioner, haha.
Alice:关掉吧
Alice: Turn it off.
其他人：你们不热吗
Others: Aren't you hot?
Alice:有一点
Alice: A little bit.
Tasha: 我觉得
Tasha: I think...
Tasha: 还需要再打几个可食用鸡蛋进去
Tasha: We need to add a few more edible eggs.
Tasha: 不然鸡蛋不够
Tasha: Otherwise, there won't be enough eggs.
Alice:蛋液用生的不加热应该也行
Alice: The egg liquid can be used raw without heating, I think.
Tasha: 嗯只不过刚
Tasha: Hmm, just now...
Tasha: 为了让那几个东西充分融合一下
Tasha: To let those ingredients fully blend.
其他人：我开空调呢
Others: I'm turning on the air conditioner.
Alice:有没有那个万能遥控
Alice: Do we have a universal remote?
Tasha: 再搞两个蛋清蛋黄进去
Tasha: Add two more egg whites and yolks.
Alice:有个按钮
Alice: There's a button.
其他人：真的假的
Others: Really?
Alice:我得看看
Alice: Let me check.
Alice:哎呀
Alice: Oh no
Alice:有的是有按钮的呀
Alice: Some of them have buttons.
Alice:找到了吗？
Alice: Did you find it?
Alice:看看滤网
Alice: Check the filter.
Alice:滤网有点脏
Alice: The filter is a bit dirty.
Alice:就这样吧
Alice: Just leave it like that.
Alice:吹不了多久了
Alice: It won't last long.
Alice:牛逼
Alice: Awesome.
Tasha: 这么热
Tasha: It's so hot.
Alice:你妈看见不打你
Alice: Your mom won't hit you if she sees it?
Alice:你吃过你们学校那个包子吗
其他人：嗯我们学校给包的啊
Others: Yeah, our school gave them out.
其他人：我学习都没咋去过学校
Others: I rarely went to school.
其他人：我四年都没咋去过学校
Others: I barely attended in four years.
其他人：一直翘课
Others: Always skipping classes.
其他人：学那些课没啥用
Others: Those classes are useless.
其他人：基本都是
Others: Mostly.
其他人：考前一周突击一下就结束嗯
Others: Just cramming a week before exams and that's it.
Alice:热呀
Alice: So hot.
Alice:我第一时间是关于
Alice: My first thought was about.
Alice:我的朋友
Alice: My friend.
Alice:他给我发了那个完整的PDF
Alice: He sent me the complete PDF.
Alice:他他他
Alice: He, he, he.
Alice:是啊
Alice: Yeah.
Alice:对
Alice: Right.
其他人：那个院的
Others: From that department.
Alice:忘记了
Alice: Forgot.
Alice:也是那种吧
Alice: It's the same kind, right?
其他人：叫啥
Others: What's it called?
Alice:不想说万一你知道呢
Alice: I don't want to say, in case you know.
其他人：那就更巧了
Others: That would be even more interesting.
Alice:不说哈哈
Alice: Not saying, haha.
其他人：那不是更好吗
Others: Isn't that better?
其他人：给你煎个蛋白吃
Others: I'll make you an egg white.
其他人：怎么样
Others: How about that?
Alice:温度越高凉的越快
Alice: The hotter it is, the faster it cools.
其他人：是吗
Others: Really?
Alice:他那个有一个什么什么一个曲线的
Alice: There's this curve or something.
其他人：昨天烧烤
Others: Barbecue yesterday.
其他人：在哪在哪搞
Others: Where was it?
Alice:昨天还是前天吧
Alice: Was it yesterday or the day before?
Alice:我们就在院里
Alice:对买的炭卧槽
Alice: Yeah, bought some charcoal, damn.
其他人：卧槽
Others: Damn.
其他人能吃吗这点
Others: Can this be eaten?
Alice:这是充的气
Alice: It's filled with gas.
Alice:保鲜的
Alice: Preserved.
Alice:你是准备读研工作还是出国读研应
Alice: Are you planning to do graduate studies here or go abroad?
其他人：读研应
Others: Graduate studies here.
其他人：该就是去他们组
Others: Just join their group.
其他人：就是在他们组
Others: Just in their group.
其他人：就是去NTU
Others: Just go to NTU.
其他人：你是研一是吗
Others: Are you a first-year graduate student?
Alice:研二哦
Alice: Second year.
其他人：那你现在还挣钱
Others: Are you still earning money now?
其他人：准备毕业是吧
Others: Preparing to graduate, right?
Alice:我是三年的
Alice: I'm on a three-year program.
其他人：哎你那个叫应应用语言学是吗
Others: Hey, your major is Applied Linguistics, right?
Alice:嗯是
Alice: Yes.
其他人：就是中文的应用语言学对
Others: Applied Linguistics in Chinese, right?
Alice:对
Alice: Right.
其他人：可以
Others: Okay.
Alice:我已经换了好几个
Alice: I've already changed majors several times.
Alice:也不是换了好几个专业就
Alice: Not really several, just...
Alice:东一榔头西一棒槌
Alice: A bit of this and that.
Alice:我们也有语聊库
其他人：但他是英语
Others: But his major is English.
其他人：你当时本科学的是物联网啊
Others: You studied Internet of Things in your undergrad?
其他人：你本科学的物联网
Others: Your undergrad was IoT?
Alice:对
Alice: Yes.
Alice:是的高中理科
Alice: Yep, science in high school.
Alice:大学工科
Alice: Engineering in college.
Alice:研究生文科
Alice: Humanities in grad school.
Alice:好玩
Alice: Fun.
Alice:怎么说呢
Alice: How to say...
Alice:我感觉我还不是很想工作
Alice: I feel like I don't really want to work yet.
其他人：那你要读博
Others: Then you should go for a PhD.
Alice:不想读博
Alice: Don't want to do a PhD.
Alice:我啊
Alice: Me?
Alice:倒也不用家里蹲吧
Alice: I don't want to just stay at home either.
其他人：就是没想好
Others: Just haven't decided yet.
Alice:也不是没想好
Alice: It's not that I haven't decided.
Alice:我的想法就是我就想一直换工作
Alice: My thought is, I just want to keep changing jobs.
Alice:你懂
Alice: You know?
Alice:怎么说呢
Alice: How should I put it?
其他人：那你去实习吗
Others: Are you going for an internship then?
Alice:确实
Alice: For sure.
Alice:啊
Alice: Ah.
其他人：那不稳定
Others: That's not stable.
Alice:我要稳定干嘛呀
Alice: Why do I need stability?
Alice:那稳定那不直接考公务员了吗
Alice: If I wanted stability, wouldn't I just take the civil service exam?
其他人：人家比较喜欢招稳定的
Others: They prefer hiring stable people.
其他人：这要做啥
Others: What should we do with this?
Alice:小料
Alice: Small pieces.
Alice:这个没用过
Alice: Haven't used this before.
Tasha: 这个剪刀是剪肉的
Tasha: These scissors are for cutting meat.
其他人：这盖太大了
Others: The lid is too big.
其他人：这个轮胎不好熟感觉弄开呗
Others: This tire doesn't seem to cook well, should we just open it?
Alice:弄开呗
Alice: Just open it then.
其他人：切开太薄了
Others: It's cut too thin.
Alice:太薄
Alice: Too thin.
其他人：切开太薄
Others: It's cut too thin.
Alice:切开怎么会薄呢
Alice: How can it be too thin if cut?
Alice:你不这样分也不也行吗
Alice: Can't you just separate it differently?
Alice:这不好切
Alice: This is hard to cut.
Alice:你切薄的话不好切
Alice: If you cut it thin, it's hard to cut.
Alice:真的吗你怎么把它立起来
Alice: Really, how do you make it stand up?
其他人：哎呦看一下
Others: Oh, look at this.
其他人：还挺新鲜的
Others: It's quite fresh.
其他人：今天几号
Others: What's the date today?
Alice: 20
Alice: The 20th.
其他人：反正冰箱温度也不知道够不够
Others: Anyway, not sure if the fridge temperature is enough.
其他人：你们那天烤的咋样
Others: How did you guys grill it that day?
其他人：熟了吗
Others: Was it cooked?
Alice:当然熟了
Alice: Of course, it was cooked.
其他人：好吃吗
Others: Was it good?
Alice:这我不能说吧
Alice: I can't really say.
其他人：这不好吃
Others: It wasn't good?
Alice:不我自己
Alice: No, I mean...
Alice:不对就是我烤的
Alice: No, it was grilled by me.
Alice:我动不动说自己烤的很难吃吧
Alice: Do I ever say that my cooking tastes bad?
Alice:也没有啊
Alice: No, I haven't.
其他人：各人烤个人的
Others: Everyone grills their own stuff.
Alice:不啊都是我烤的
Alice: No, I cooked everything.
Alice:但是那个啥烟是那个Su
Alice: But the smoke was from that Su thing.
Alice:腌挺好的
Alice: The marinade was good.
Tasha: 能帮我拿一下吗
Tasha: Can you help me take this?
Alice:说一开始的碳不好找
Alice: At first, the charcoal was hard to find.
Alice:其他都挺好的
Alice: But everything else was fine.
其他人：现在切开
Others: Cut it now.
其他人：这不烤完就成牛
Others: If we grill it more, it'll turn into beef.
Alice:给我
Alice: Give it to me.
Alice:因为搞完卫生太累了
Alice: Cleaning up was so tiring.
Alice:不想刷了
Alice: I don't want to wash anymore.
其他人：还有海绵去哪
Others: Where did the sponge go?
其他人：好问题
Others: Good question.
其他人：他这个刀也没有架子没
Others: His knife doesn't have a holder, does it?
Alice:嗯
Alice: Hmm.
Alice:哎他们干嘛去了
Alice: Hey, where did they go?
Alice:拿快递吗
Alice: To pick up a package?
其他人：好像是吧
Others: Seems like it.
Alice:这是这的吧
Alice: This belongs here, right?
Tasha: 这些都是买的
Tasha: These were all bought.
Alice:锅也是我们买的
Alice: We also bought the pot.
其他人：这能用钢丝刷吗
Others: Can we use a wire brush on this?
Alice:用吧
Alice: Sure.
Tasha: 可以
Tasha: Yeah.
其他人：刷不干净以后也不用
Others: If it can't be cleaned, we won't use it next time.
其他人：不用就不刷了
Others: If we don't use it, we won't clean it.
Alice:确实确实
Alice: True, true.
Alice:你平时在家做饭吗
Alice: Do you cook at home?
其他人：你觉得我像做饭吗
Others: Do I look like I cook?
Alice:我不知道啊
Alice: I don't know.
Alice:你做吗
Alice: Do you?
其他人：也做过但是一般我也不在家做得少
Others: I have cooked before, but usually, I don't cook much at home.
其他人：他们到哪了
Others: Where did they go?
Tasha: 小薇
Tasha: Tasha.
其他人：酥皮已经起来了
Others: The puff pastry has risen.
其他人：但是中间不知道是没熟
Others: But the middle seems undercooked.
Tasha: 等20分钟到了之后
Tasha: Wait until 20 minutes are up.
Tasha: 然后把所有的那个蛋挞皮没关系
Tasha: Then use all the tart crusts, it's okay.
Tasha:  这啥哦哦哦好会啊
Tasha: What's this? Oh, you're so good at this.
其他人：就这样
Others: Just like that.
其他人：这个多少钱
Others: How much is this?
Tasha: 这个50块钱
Tasha: This is 50 yuan.
其他人： 5块钱
Others: 5 yuan?
Tasha:  50
Tasha: 50.
其他人：那其实扔了也合适
Others: Then it's actually worth throwing away.
Tasha: 啊
Tasha: Ah.
其他人：他回你了吗
Others: Did he reply to you?
Tasha: 打电话我们
Tasha: Let's call him.
其他人：这俩东西感觉已经
Others: These two things feel like they are already...
其他人：凉了呀
Others: Cold.
Tasha: 哪俩东西
Tasha: Which two things?
其他人：这个
Others: These.
Tasha: 哎呀
Tasha: Oh no.
Tasha: 你觉凉了吗
Tasha: Do you think it's cold?
其他人：还行有点凉
Others: It's okay, a bit cold.
其他人：好好学生推的高级
Others: Good students push the advanced stuff.
Tasha: 别别别别别
Tasha: No, no, no, no, no.
Tasha: 还没有结束呢
Tasha: It's not over yet.
其他人：这不能拿住
Others: This can't be held.
Tasha: 可以啊
Tasha: Yes, it can.
Tasha:  用用刀用刀
Tasha: Use a knife, use a knife.
Alice:不不那个平的长的我
Alice: No, no, the flat long one, I...
Alice:我好像搁那了吧
Alice: I think I put it there.
Tasha: 搁哪了
Tasha: Where did you put it?
Alice:那个架上
Alice: On the rack.
其他人：你这刀干净吗
Others: Is this knife clean?
Tasha: 都搁那了肯定就干净了
Tasha: If it's put there, it must be clean.
其他人：我这这几个刀割里边真的很危险
Others: These knives inside are really dangerous.
Tasha: 这就是你家芒果啊
Tasha: This is your mango?
Tasha: 不是芒果
Tasha: Not a mango.
Tasha: 啊菠萝
Tasha: Ah, it's a pineapple.
其他人：但是熟不了
Others: But it can't ripen.
其他人：刀我还觉得得换个地方
Others: I think the knife needs to be moved.
其他人：给他切一半
Others: Cut it in half for him.
其他人：咱先吃
Others: Let's eat first.
Alice:嗯嗯嗯
Alice: Mm, mm, mm.
Alice:安格斯什么来着
Alice: What was Angus again?
Alice:不是这个
Alice: Not this one.
Alice:不是那个吧
Alice: It's not that one, right?
其他人：这不是就这个吗
Others: Isn't it this one?
Alice:是这个吗
Alice: Is it this one?
其他人：小吃有
Others: There's snacks.
Alice:小吃
Alice: Snacks.
Alice:是麦乐鸡
Alice: It's McNuggets.
其他人：麦乐鸡是啥
Others: What's McNuggets?
其他人：鸡翅
Others: Chicken wings.
Alice:鸡块
Alice: Chicken nuggets.
Alice:谢谢
Alice: Thank you.
其他人： 5个的
Others: A set of 5.
Alice:5个还是4个忘了
Alice: Was it 5 or 4? I forgot.
其他人：你点的是那个
Others: You ordered that one.
其他人：呃四件套吗
Others: Uh, the four-piece set?
Alice:三件套吧
Alice: Three-piece set, I think.
Alice:三件套
Alice: Three-piece set.
其他人：三件套
Others: Three-piece set.
其他人：嗯没有薯条
Others: Yeah, no fries.
Alice:哦四
Alice: Oh, four.
其他人：四件套
Others: Four-piece set.
其他人：那就是这4个
Others: So it's these 4.
其他人：这是那可
Others: This is that, right?
其他人：能别人单点的
Others: Maybe someone ordered individually.
其他人：然后你点了薯条
Others: And you ordered fries.
Alice:是的
Alice: Yes.
Alice:谢谢
Alice: Thank you.
其他人：给你酱
Others: Here's the sauce.
Alice:我不要酱
Alice: I don't want the sauce.
Alice:算了给我
Alice: Never mind, give it to me.
Alice:别动好谢谢
Alice: Don't touch it, thanks.
Alice:咖啡
Alice: Coffee.
Alice:哎不对
Alice: Oh, wait.
Alice:我的是那个可乐
Alice: Mine was the cola.
Alice:但我不喝
Alice: But I'm not drinking it.
Alice:给那个谁吧
Alice: Give it to someone else.
Alice:你喝吗
Alice: Do you want it?
Alice:那你来吧
Alice: Then you take it.
Alice:是咖啡吗
Alice: Is it coffee?
Alice:看看
Alice: Let's see.
Alice:忘了我点的是咖啡还是可乐
Alice: I forgot if I ordered coffee or cola.
Alice:哎
Alice: Ugh.
Alice:难搞啊
Alice: This is so tricky.
Alice:这薯条
Alice: These fries...
Alice:对打一下吧
Alice: Yeah, let's give it a try.
其他人：你的肉松在哪
Others: Where's your pork floss?
其他人：这肉松在这买的
Others: This pork floss was bought here.
其他人：不咋地
Others: Not that great.
Tasha: 这还不咋地
Tasha: This is not that great?
Tasha: 不是他
Tasha: It's not him.
Tasha: 他只是看上去不咋地
Tasha: He just looks not that great.
Alice:他是风格
Alice: It's his style.
其他人：好好肉松吗
Others: Is the pork floss good?
Tasha: 嗯
Tasha: Yeah.
Alice:鸡吧
Alice: Chicken.
其他人：鸡肉嗯
Others: Chicken, yeah.
其他人：鸡肉便宜
Others: Chicken is cheap.
其他人：哎你那这是啥时候调的
Others: When did you mix this?
Tasha: 这个
Tasha: This one?
其他人：嗯
Others: Yeah.
Tasha: 刚刚调的
Tasha: Just mixed it.
其它人：这里都加上炼乳
Tasha: 嗯
Tasha: Yeah.
Alice:沙拉酱
Alice: And some salad dressing.
其他人：再加上
Others: Add some more.
Tasha: 味美滋
Tasha: Some mayonnaise.
其他人：美乃滋吧
Others: Mayonnaise, right?
Alice:呃美乃滋
Alice: Uh, mayonnaise.
Alice:哎我为什么不把那个也一起放进去
Alice: Why don't I just put that in as well?
其他人：糖度报表
Others: The sugar level is off the charts.
其他人：你为啥不喝可乐
Others: Why don't you drink cola?
Alice:我不喝碳酸饮料
Alice: I don't drink carbonated drinks.
其他人：就不喜欢喝
Others: Just don't like them?
Alice:嗯
Alice: Yeah.
其他人：蛋挞我觉得差不多了
Others: I think the egg tarts are about done.
Tasha: 蛋挞拿出来
Tasha: Take out the egg tarts.
Tasha: 然后把它翻成面
Tasha: And then flip them over.
Tasha: 担担面对
Tasha: Facing the noodles.
Tasha: 就是把那个锡纸取出来
Tasha: Just remove the foil.
Tasha: 然后把它翻个面再烤
Tasha: Then flip them over and bake again.
Tasha: 再烤5分钟
Tasha: Bake for another 5 minutes.
其他人： 这么讲究
Others: So particular.
其他人：那你直接把直接上边加热
Others: Why don't you just heat the top directly?
其他人：下边不加热不就行了
Others: And leave the bottom unheated?
Tasha: 呃不是
Tasha: Uh, no.
Tasha: 他就是为了让底部烤的更酥脆一些
Tasha: It's to make the bottom crispier.
Tasha: 才这样
Tasha: That's why.
Alice:打完之后软了我真服
Alice: It got soft after being beaten, I can't believe it.
其他人：确实不能打
Others: You really shouldn't beat it.
Alice:那你为什么不说呀
Alice: Then why didn't you say so?
Alice:尝一下
Alice: Try it.
Alice:没纸
Alice: No paper.
Alice:啊
Alice: Ah.
其他人：我忘了
Others: I forgot.
其他人：我点的是脆脆薯条
Others: I ordered crispy fries.
其他人：普通薯条
Others: Regular fries.
Alice:嗯
Alice: Hmm.
Alice:那你就寄希望于别人也寄不住吧
Alice: Then you just hope that others don't mind either.
Alice:那就无所谓了
Alice: Then it doesn't matter.
其他人：m你这筷子用的不是很熟悉啊
Others: You're not very familiar with using those chopsticks, huh?
Alice:吃薯条吗
Alice: Want some fries?
其他人：你点的啥
Others: What did you order?
Tasha: 我点的嗯
Tasha: I ordered, um.
其他人：嗯
Others: Hmm.
Tasha: 一个汉堡
Tasha: A burger.
Tasha: 两个
Tasha: Two.
Tasha: 两个香芋派
Tasha: Two taro pies.
其他人：  尝尝你今天这甜度的爆表
Others: Try them, your sweetness level is off the charts today.
其他人：你先弄好位置
Others: Get the position right first.
其他人：然后再弄过去这个巧克
Others: Then move the chocolate over.
Tasha: 行
Tasha: Got it.
其他人：力还没化呢
Others: The chocolate isn't melted yet.
Alice:所以才爆浆呀
Alice: That's why it bursts.
Tasha: 巧克力肯定
Tasha: The chocolate definitely—
其他人：我就现在还没化
Others: It's still not melted now.
其他人：现在没化不就不对了
Others: It should have melted by now.
Tasha: 他们怎么还没回来
Tasha: Why haven't they come back yet?
Tasha: 去了都有一个小时了
Tasha: They've been gone for an hour.
Alice:他们会不会掉进了时空缝隙里
Alice: Did they fall into a time warp or something?
Alice:哈哈哈
Alice: Hahaha.
Tasha: 没有一个人能回来
Tasha: No one can come back.
Alice:无人生还
Alice: No survivors.
其他人：这我觉得和学校卖的那种蛋挞
Others: I think this is like the egg tarts they sell at school.
Alice:嗯回来了
Alice: Yeah, they're back.
其他人：我已经帮你把所有碗都刷完了
Others: I already washed all the dishes for you.
Jake:哦
Jake: Oh.
Jake:确实来给你们吃
Jake: Sure, let me get you some food.
Jake:快递
Jake: Delivery.
Shure: 这么香
Shure: Smells so good.
Katrina: 好香啊
Katrina: So fragrant.
其他人：要加班喽
Others: Looks like we have to work overtime.
Katrina: 我终于可以戴眼镜了
Katrina: I can finally wear glasses.
Lucia: 哇洗洗手
Lucia: Wow, wash your hands.
Jake:吃吃汉堡
Jake: Let's have some burgers.
Jake:吃蛋挞
Jake: Eat some egg tarts.
Jake:吃什么呀
Jake: What should we eat?
Jake:蛋挞是吧
Jake: Egg tarts, right?
Jake:好有什么好的吗有
Jake: Okay, are there any good ones?
其他人：你们有人点的那个脆脆薯条吗
Others: Did anyone order the crispy fries?
其他人:如果没有人点的就是我点的
Others: If no one ordered, then it's mine.
其他人:但是我忘了你点的
Others: But I forgot you ordered it.
Jake:吃两个呗
Jake: Have two then.
Tasha: 要吃个肉松小贝吗
Tasha: Do you want a pork floss cake?
Jake:好
Jake: Sure.
Tasha: 啊
Tasha: Ah.
Jake:菠萝要
Jake: Want some pineapple?
其他人：你要准备好
Others: Get ready.
Jake:可以要啊
Jake: Of course, I want it.
其他人：都给你们杀
Others: We'll get it for you.
其他人：不是给你们
Others: Not for you.
其他人：咱们刷吧哈哈哈
Others: Let's wash up, haha.
Jake:哈哈
Jake: Haha.
Jake:严谨严谨
Jake: Be meticulous.
Jake:吃点什么呢
Jake: What should we eat?
Lucia: 哪个是我的来着
Lucia: Which one is mine?
Lucia: 我又忘了
Lucia: I forgot again.
Jake:没关系盲盒
Jake: No worries, it's a surprise box.
Jake:麦当劳盲盒
Jake: McDonald's surprise box.
Jake:对麦当劳盲盒
Jake: Yes, McDonald's surprise box.
其他人：差不多一个小时
Others: About an hour.
Jake:因为路就很远
Jake: Because the road is really long.
Alice:走路去的吗
Alice: Did you walk here?
Jake:对
Jake: Yes.
Lucia: 这个好像是牛奶
Lucia: This looks like milk.
Alice:饮品在这里
Alice: The drinks are over here.